so how do I pronounce your name
uh Master Anubis Master Anubis yeah
Master Anubis uh where are you from
originally where are you from
uh it is in Europe it's in Spain
Spain yes okay
it might be better to do this without
the mask if we can
are you open to doing that
uh
let's see how it goes here
um
tell me about your family growing up
growing up oh that's a that's a bag
yeah so as far as I remember
my family does have a well they have a
Catholic background
but then
uh they got caught into a cult which is
Mormonism
and thus I grew up
very Mormon oriented and then my parents
got split
and then there are bouncing between
Italy and Spain for
easily a decade
and so
when custody is a little bit
one-sided that's kind of what happens
and then as I get older or I got older
my mom left Europe and now here to to
America and that's when I was 14 is when
you came to the US at 14 yes
to Los Angeles yes
and where was your father
my father was
um
it's not I don't know I I think he was
uh working trying to figure out his life
while I was with my mother
and then when I was with him when he
happened to take advantage of custody he
would be somewhere else but I mean less
than or spend time with my grandparents
growing up too so your father wasn't a
big part of your life not uh not too
much no what kind of how would you
describe your childhood
um kind of a chaotic but at least I
learned a lot of the ropes I had to
understand that that's what life was I'm
here and before you know you're gonna be
over here and then you're gonna get
settled with it still friends in one
country and then you're gonna be another
from one and you never knew what
happened when it happened you had to
just do it a lot of turmoil yeah
you finish High School yeah yeah yeah
yeah what were you like in high school
um in high school I was very
uh secluded
um my mentality again this has to do
with the ideals of Mormonism that their
kids are bad for you they are vulgar
they are too
worldly I guess that's what that was the
term so they do drugs and they drink and
they have wild sex and you're not
supposed to be doing that and After High
School you did what so After High School
one of the high school um oh no I uh I
went to college but then they probably
do the Mormon tour which is this end the
guys what the women do but mostly As the
men
to uh someplace for two years you live
out of two suitcases you have to pay for
it yourself and what are you doing is
collecting more members of that church
so they can pay their dually con they do
do the contribution to the church that's
basically the model and you dress up
very conservative and you walk with your
shirt and like the musical they have in
Broadway now the things to become more
musical you look just like that
but they send you to all over the world
in my case I got sent to Salt Lake City
which is really ironic but that's where
I went
and uh that's what I did uh before I
went to
um
back to college and I ended up going to
the
I don't know how I still don't know how
this happened because I really meant not
to happen I ended up with the Mormon
University which is BYU and Utah
they sent me a letter and I was saying
I'm like oh great I don't want to go
there but my uncle got involved
he basically speeded the papers
that I didn't know they had done
anything before I knew what I was there
so you were trying to get away from the
Mormon I was from Utah I've been already
there too long and I went back to it for
college and
that's that's what happened
and then since you've been out of school
what what kind of things you're working
I take it yeah yeah you have a job but
yeah my feelings in the in the engine
marketing but you have an interesting
fetish it looks like I do I do yeah tell
me about that so
I ended up exploring the internet
and not so much in the places where I
was forbidden to go uh because I was
very active still Mormonism at this
point but what I did do is I played with
this video game it's called Second Life
and then this actually some where are
you is not a video game but it is a
virtual Universe where you can
experiment and and basically become and
experienced life and different things
I'm just plugging along doing my thing
and I met this woman there who dressed a
little bit like me
and she claimed she was a slave and I'm
like what what does that mean so she
educated me on that she explained me a
lot of things and I got a lot of the
education in what is the the let's call
the healthy BDSM universe meaning and I
do mean by healthy is that we have
models of uh consent respect and trust
and none found those three things
everything else in BDSM is built so as
that's what I learned a lot a lot of
that and I got into that while I was
kind of experimenting things on the
average world but I was not enough
I went full in because in that and that
virtual reality
you become effectively something else
something else when you join in
which is well let's do this right away I
immerse myself in in my identity here
and then and that I have now as Master
Anubis and when that was not enough
then I just jump in here in the local
area and that's taking me throughout
California throughout Europe through
Canada and uh so far I think that's all
the places I've been where I met I meet
this community that understands the same
thing that that I like in the pretty
much focusing on this thing which is
fetishism what is it that you like
because the outfit is unusual for you
yeah
let's talk about this the fetishism
revolves around the one thing that
causes some kind of arousal uh in this
case is latex latex uh hafsa smell it
has uh a texture is it's a kind of a
huggy
um
it does things to your skin where you
feel this this kind of a weird look like
a hug so to speak
um it's shiny and it complements your
body
so women especially like that because it
really is
act it makes those curves look really
nice which I happen to like a lot too uh
and that's that's where my FedEx system
comes in mainly in seeing the female
form adopt this this kind of material
and looks gorgeous hot and amazing
um but then again I also like it because
it is
kind of when what I get in and I have to
say when I do go to an event when I do
go to uh even even now
just a degree of excitement as you pull
the outfit as you're putting things
together it's always a thrill uh I don't
know what kind of endurance endorphins
it is exactly but it's it's a thrilled
thing to experience and especially
coming to the party walking in and then
uh be sort of the object of attention
and then that leads to the other aspects
of BDSM that we can talk later if you
wanna if one go over those things
and you so you go to parties oh yeah and
you'll be dressed oh yeah yes costume
and you will
eventually lead to some kind of
interaction that oh yeah yeah yeah the
um I'm not sure that I always go with
that plan but usually that's what
happened
um I don't there's there's men go to
this place or to this parties or do this
events in three different ways
there's the business suit which I hate
because I read that Mormonism I'm up to
here wearing a suit uh two casual jeans
and t-shirt I think it's kind of lame
and then something like this
if I were to go to an event any of those
two ways that they I just forget it just
it is it's pointless to me
uh this this
um fetishism or this this uh outfit or
or this sort of style is
the only way I go is the only thing that
the only way that uh to me becomes value
to to experi to experience and yeah
again once I get there I do get
surrounded by people I do get
photographed a lot I do get people ask
me questions usually two or three and
then run away because they don't know
what else to do with me they actually
get the company you look great oh thank
you
and then they got nothing else and they
go away
um and given that the environment is
louder and everything they might not
hear if I say something else because
um
when I do wear this which is one of my
go-to helmets
um I definitely stand out uh but they
may not hear me they might understand me
so that that's that's that's the the
little thing that does happen sometimes
and this costume enhances your whole
sexual experience yeah so once again is
the girl assignment dressing up and then
the personification and then getting a
new identity that I can really have no
boundaries once again when you have
grown up in a in a in a world of
Mormonism there are things that I'm
still processing there are things that
I'm still
trying to
um escape and let go of
and becoming this I can I don't have to
worry about that I can just
check that out and doesn't exist for me
so it allows me again to free my mind
and that's one of my the things that I
that I particularly do in this party in
this uh in the scene
there's people in video Sam that are
a needle play players I mean they use
needles on people
they're like that I don't get it but
they do they they pour hot waxing with
people they like that that wouldn't work
on me obviously uh electricity
um
spanking I do have a vlogger here
because I do have some people that like
a vlogger I can do it too
but my thing or thing that I do with the
things that I I prime myself on is is
psychological play is getting in
someone's head and do things in there
and again back to rules the consent
trust and and uh
and um
healthy BDSM
I go in there and do things that causes
uh arousal and reaction on people and
seeing that or being part of that is
what causes me the same reaction I would
I would think wearing the mask and this
in the whole costume which is you know
makes you Anonymous yes you're like a
mystery man and yes I'm sure that's
arousing for some women uh yes and and
this is Again part of that identity and
and uh I don't there's very few people
who know me when I don't have this on uh
only the people that I've um
um
well you know when there's when I go
when we go to events for multiple days
and I don't wear this 24 7 like you stay
in a hotel like well obviously there's
some people that are going to recognize
me and those people that see my badge
I'm like oh it's you no it's not
but that's what I don't I don't get I
don't get too too full any longer so
yeah
when when the sexual act finally happens
you are still in a in costume or you're
naked like most of well the that depends
what you what you mean by the sexual act
um there is some of some argument about
um back to BDSM and being one thing and
sex being something else if I if I just
were to explain the difference between
the two
BDSM includes things like bondage
includes things like masochism includes
things like uh a discipline humiliation
a lot of things things like that that
Ackerman wasn't correct but includes the
specific things
um so they can be done and it may not
include penetration
sex is sex that we all know what that is
uh but uh there's there's a really weird
area where they can come together
but the problem is that some people make
that those two things join without back
to what I said consent trust and respect
and that's what it goes about so
um the things that cause people arousals
don't need to lead direct specifically
to to Safe penetration for example or
touching anyone's private parts
they I know I've had I've had people
that I use this on and it causes a very
arousal reaction and I didn't touch
anything here or on the breast or
nothing and they just
they find it and then I've had to like
almost pick your mom and put it on my
sofa because they were so overview
overcharged with endorphins that they
have to take a break they have to get
some water they have to recover and uh
that's uh
that's that's the the funny thing about
what is classified as sexual uh
experience in the other wagon which is
just sex so again depends which one do
you mean
interesting world isn't it uh it's it's
it's uh it's getting very very
fascinating again
um
back to what I was saying before
understanding the mind understand the
brain what makes people tick what makes
people respond to things sometimes it's
worse sometimes it's action sometimes is
the combination how you say things all
of that can have an effect if you know
how to
get in someone's head and do things
um and uh
and other times it's the the effect of
the equipment again back to this vlogger
that they know what makes them take they
know how to respond to things they might
say to me I like it when you do it like
this I like it here but not here do it
harder do it less I like it and then
that communication is what I can amplify
the experience and an effect is is uh
it's funny to think about it but
we all did
growing up the things that we didn't
really make any funny connections when
we play superhero
this is kind of a adult version of
superhero and I still play but it's a
different kind of play I don't throw my
my Bob my uh my rope and climb into a
building but I am dressed up and I may
have someone tied up and I may give a
slight choke that's a different kind of
play uh yet in a super superhero Persona
so to speak we played a tag you know you
touch one person and the other person
runs and is having an authority over the
other person which is kind of what
domination is and so we all grew up
playing things we just now got older and
we are kind of using the same parts of
our brain but amplifying or changing the
way we play but essentially we're doing
our four lives I would think
communication again is key in these
relationships absolutely I cannot say
that enough communication is so so so
important
um otherwise it runs into
misunderstandings it can lead to abuse
so I do have several interviews with
whoever I'm participating because
um no one wants to have that done and I
don't want to I don't want to do that to
anybody
I would think when you're at a
get-together
women will see you and they'll know
right away whether they're interested or
not because you're just so unusual from
uh everyone else there it's funny so I
get I get I feel the kinds of reactions
there's people that all these women they
see me and come right at me and they
want to touch me they want to put their
hands on me and they can't stop there's
all the people that want to see me that
stare at me and they they want to skip
the touch and go into do things to me
and then they saw the ones that think
I'm scary
and so they stand back but they can't
stop staring
so
um it's it's uh it goes all over the
place
was there something in your childhood
that you think maybe led to this
ah yes yes I figure this out uh years
ago
I
um
I was
I don't remember I'm gonna say it's it
was before the divorce so I had to be
between six and seven
um
the 1980s uh Spider-Man was big the
cartoons especially was still big but
the cartoons were were either Highland
exploded like with the Marvel universe
or whatever but uh I do know that I was
watching cartoons and I was just like
running the hallway going all over the
place and uh my mom had this uh Fabric
and he threw she threw in my face and
wrapped it on my face and my head and
then tied it up kind of tight uh put it
tight enough so it wouldn't move so I
can go play and do my thing and so I'm
just having a good time you know
throwing my imaginary weave all over the
all over the hallway but I do know and I
remember what it felt to have that thing
on my head or my neck or my face and
being it happened being the sort of what
basically a status have this thing I
have my head right now they have the
kind of same sensation and being again
back to superhero so I definitely think
it's a good link between that particular
day or that evening
to waking up all this and into fetishism
does does put what a lot of people call
vanilla sex even appeal to you
ah
I guess I could do vanilla a little bit
but vanilla all the time no
and uh and I do and
in this extremes between the two I mean
there's extreme vanilla in this extreme
let's call it kinky sex
and when it gets into the extreme of
kinky sex I think it becomes rough sex
but I think for me kind of the middle
ground where it becomes more
uh more interesting is back to what I
just said I said before
getting another identity row let's call
it role play that role play can lead
into other things and just experiment a
little bit with toys but not to become
not in way it becomes say violent or
rough sex that that's my extreme but I
don't play and again here on the vanilla
on the left on the far far on this side
okay a little bit but
that's gonna get boring how extreme does
your BDSM
I'm not that extreme I mean I as I
mentioned before there are people who
are
stabbing needles and they're they're
doing uh I know I have I had a friend on
uh in Spain that uh
she actually injects a solution that
causes a kind of euphoria it's basically
it's a it's exactly what what a nurse
would do and she knows exactly the
amount to put in and the way that she's
drugging you apparently is safe I don't
know all the details I never asked for
this but that's gonna win the far end as
well as with with fire with poking
things minus very basic on on what we
call impact clip which is what I'm
holding here in my hand uh and
and again back to psychological play and
I think that would be a little on the
extreme
and I do say that because there are
people who I cannot participate on the
activity I can
figure out I can I can all right we have
a little bit of there's some things here
that have not had you cannot handle your
own you have not solved these issues I
cannot wake up or pick up any triggers
because it would be a bad idea and and
there's people that cannot engage in
those activities because it will not be
healthy uh there's people who have a
little bit more of a healthy
another we're not unhealthy but someone
who's worked through their issues then
yeah we can do that but there's people
who will have some kind of drama I mean
I mentioned mine
we'll have something that some kind of
baggage that we are either dealing with
we haven't looked into and uh we're
ignoring or is that effectively causing
us some problems
being able to participate with those
people is always good just be careful
and that's basically My Philosophy do
you think
our fetishes stem from some kind of
trauma they went through as a kid
that would be a question for uh for a
psychologist if I don't have that degree
but I do know that there is is they are
usually those come through something
that uh
uh that does get waking up now trauma
and like I mentioned my thing what led
me to this is not I don't think it's
drama you're not necessarily trauma but
something they went through as a child
yeah of course oh if that's what you
mean absolutely yes everything that we
are made of uh that keeps manifested is
something that we have here that when
we're another we're trying to recover
we're trying to bring back up we're
trying to enjoy again we're just having
found the means to do it and there's so
many uh vanilla people and I do mean
back to you uh when I went to school in
uh in Utah that there's so many so many
things that are suppressed that they are
not allowed to explore or understand and
uh they just
they're just boxing into this universe
that they know they don't they haven't
even figured out who they are let alone
what are all these things that excite
them they make them have joy they they
they're very very limited so again
when I do reach out when I'm Reach Out
by them uh I do help them to
find more joy in life with those things
uh people who are sort of stepping away
like man I'm gonna call help me and
that's sort of what I'm doing
how did the cult that you call it um
that you came from affect this part of
your life
that is
um I suppose you can edit it but um
there is
um Mormonism does have a part of it that
those claim Egyptian Origins
uh a specifically Origins that have to
do with funerals and and the way that
the people were in Egypt died and they
were transitioned into the Afterlife
the the founder of the religion claimed
to have found uh
writings or let's call it Papyrus that
uh came from Abraham and now he's saying
they Abraham wrote this and now I'm the
prophet I'm going to give it to you
essentially what he did
that's a lie I looked at those those
Papyrus I look at those uh hero graphics
and they have nothing to do with other
more about the transition between the
dead and the next life and who who
participate in that
I do
the role of Anubis is here's the channel
to transition from the from the living
to a safe path to the afterlife joined
with Osiris that's what Anubis does so
when I saw the Papyrus and so high was
doctored like the the the person that
was supposed to make that transition
they took out Anubis out of there they
added that they took him out of the
Papyrus and put some guy with a machete
and that's not correct that's not
accurate so in fact me becoming Anubis
in my study about age of duology because
I didn't just want to dress up I wanted
to understand I wanted to really embrace
it when I figure that out and I looked
at that from what I had studied I'm like
this is wrong and this is a lie this you
have this by Paris you have Anubis now
whatever this is the whole thing is a
fraud the whole thing is of bloody life
so if that's your question this
understanding this or becoming this
really
put me in a position to
fracture the whole the whole religion
and expose the life that I was living
with that I had and in effect in a way I
knew it saved me from keep
drinking the Kool-Aid
Master Anubis what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned from
your
Adventures as a
as a BDSM fetishist many things but I
want to say the thing is the most most
value the most value is acceptance
the most value is
don't see people from what you have been
told that they are see people who
they are again we live even now we live
in a very polarized world big politics
I'm not good into but you know what I
mean by that that we have to uh have
certain stigmas about people and and
whatever but in this experience that
I've been having
I have met people that are all kinds of
things
and I don't get to judge him I'm not
supposed to I did that before and I
wasn't a thing to a good thing to be
doing
um there people everyone is trying to
achieve a degree of happiness if they
catch it great but in the struggle to
get there the last thing the last thing
they need is someone saying you are not
doing your life correctly you are not
living your life the way that I think
you should be living nobody needs that
if anything needs encouragement to
explore more which is back to what I
said before that I'm doing but
accepting people for the journey they
are
trying to figure out or that they're
adjourning journeying through is
um probably the thing of most value
because again acceptance open to all
kinds of doors open so kinds of uh
avenues for and essentially is love if
you get that if you figure that out and
you can be
um
open-minded and be uh
good to everybody they'll trust you and
your Universe changes too so it's it's a
one it's it's it's a win-win on that but
again uh the this world of BDSM you you
do enjoy you do enjoy the com the
company of many different kinky people
with many different things that trigger
them to be kinky and are you in a
universality of ways and they are what
they are and that's fine because that's
their life and I just get to enjoy
whether I learn from them and maybe
they're learning from me I'm not sure
about that but uh coming from my heart
where I have come from is vastly
different to accept as opposed to judge
all right Master Anubis thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
very interesting lifestyle Elite thank
you